OK, so imagine this for a
second.
America's next huge domestic
spending program.
Maybe a trillion dollars, right?
But it's not going towards, you
know, big bridges or finding
cures for diseases.
It's something, well, totally
different.
Unexpected.
Maybe we're talking about
something that feels a bit like
an old New Deal program, but
with a really, really big twist.
And that's exactly what we're
digging into today.
The sources we've been looking
at, they present this really
provocative idea.
What if this thing people call
the deportation industrial
complex?
What if it's not just about
enforcing immigration law?
OK, what else would it be?
Well, what if it's actually
working like America's new WPA?
You know the Works Progress
Administration, except now it's
like a deportation works
program.
Works program, yeah.
And we're going to unpack that,
how this idea sort of reframes
what might be happening, what it
means for the country, for
communities, the economy, all of
it.
Our job today really is to pull
out the key bits from these
sources.
Help you understand this pretty
complicated and often hidden
system, right?
So maybe let's start with the
original WPA back in the 1930s,
just to set the scene.
That was pure New Deal stuff,
wasn't it?
Putting millions back to work
during the Depression.
Absolutely building things you
could see and touch.
Parks, post offices, even
murals, monuments.
Yeah, tangible things like the
sources say, shovels in the
ground, lunch boxes and
paychecks.
Yeah, very idealistic in a way.
Exactly.
Now jump to today, the Twenty
20s.
The analysis we read suggests a
totally different kind of
crisis.
Not poverty like back then, but
abundance.
Abundance.
How so?
Well, they call it a surplus.
Specifically surplus.
Capital surplus, capacity
surplus.
Will they talk about this
trillion dollar military
industrial machine that doesn't
really have an obvious war to
fight right now?
No big foreign interventions
soaking it all up.
OK, I see where this is going.
So the question becomes, what do
you do with all that money, that
momentum, that infrastructure
when the empire isn't expanding
outwards anymore?
You turn it inwards.
That's what the sources argue.
You turn inward.
Right, let's unpack that because
wow, that's a major shift.
This idea that the forever war
didn't end, it just changed
coordinates.
The map flipped from global to
domestic.
That's a really powerful way to
frame it.
And that domestic focus, I
guess, leads us right to how
these sources define this whole
thing.
Exactly.
Which brings us to their core
concept, the Deportation
Industrial Complex, and they
define it very specifically.
It's a system of interlocking
public, private and quasi
governmental entities that
generate revenue, employment and
political capital through mass
deportation, logistics and
infrastructure.
It's a mouthful, but every part
matters.
Revenue, employment, political
capital through logistics and
infrastructure.
And what's really interesting
here, based on the research, is
how this system, yeah, it looks
like immigration enforcement on
the surface, but they say it
actually functions like an
economic stimulus.
Right.
It's not really about border
security, they argue.
It's about jobs.
It's about procurement.
Yeah, contracts.
And they give examples, right?
Like turning old Walmarts into
processing centers.
Exactly.
Every abandoned Walmart into a
processing hub, or every small
town Sheriff's Department into a
federal subcontractor.
Even like every ICE vehicle into
a rolling paycheck for someone,
it permeates down to that level.
A rolling paycheck.
And this is really crucial to
understanding how it works.
According to these analysis, the
logic is not moral, it is
mechanical.
Mechanical meaning.
Meaning it operates based on
inputs and outputs, on
efficiency, on process, not
really on ethics or, you know,
the human cost in the
traditional sense.
It's about making the machine
run OK.
So if the map flipped inward,
who or what is the new target
for all this mechanical focus?
Well, the sources point to a
huge number, an estimated 2030
million people, undocumented
immigrants.
And they're described as being
scattered throughout American
cities and suburbs, farms and
factories, restaurants and ride
shares everywhere, basically.
And crucially, the sources don't
frame them as a threat, which is
the usual narrative we hear.
No, not at all.
They use terms like a
demographic, an opportunity,
even a billable object.
A billable object that's.
It is, and it raises a big
question, right?
How does just having a large
population justify spending all
this money?
Yeah, how does that work?
Well, the sources talk about
what they see as a major
miscalculation.
They suggest that the Democratic
Party believed it had engineered
checkmate.
Checkmate.
How?
The thinking was apparently that
by allowing the undocumented
population to swell, they hope
to make deportation logistically
impossible.
Just too many people to spread
out.
OK, that makes a kind of sense.
But the argument goes that
completely backfired, the
sources say.
If you tell the DOJI, see DHS
and hundreds of private
contractors that there are
infinite people to process and
remove, you're not creating a
barrier, you're opening a
faucet.
You're giving them an endless
supply of work.
Wow, so the sheer scale didn't
deter spending it justified it.
Exactly.
It connects to this bigger
principle.
You don't deter federal spending
by making something vast.
You justify it.
Yeah, think about like the F35
fighter jet program.
Right, the one where they spread
the manufacturing across almost
every state.
Precisely.
To lock in political support
everywhere.
Make it too big and too
distributed to fail,
essentially, and the sources
draw a Direct Line.
Now they say deportation touches
all 50 states.
Same logic.
That F35 point makes it crystal
clear you don't tell a trillion
dollar machine there's no work.
Nope.
You give it a workload.
And this isn't just tied to one
party or president, is it?
Not according to this analysis.
They're very clear.
It's bipartisan.
They say the pivot became
explicit maybe when Trump
returned in 2025, hypothetically
speaking, based on their
timeline.
But they stressed it was already
happening under Biden and even
Obama deported record number.
Yeah.
The point is, the machine
transcends partisanship.
It has its own life, its own
momentum.
And because it touches all 50
states, as you said, that
creates, what do they call it,
institutional loyalty?
Yeah, exactly.
Institutional loyalty.
It spreads the benefits wide.
They suggest that from the mayor
of a sanctuary city to the
sheriff of a red county,
everyone gets a slice.
Everyone gets a slice.
Think.
About it Logistics crews in
Idaho, detention builders in
Alabama, software vendors in
Portland, data analysts in
Cleveland.
It's a whole ecosystem.
So that buy in makes it
incredibly hard to dismantle I
imagine.
Very resilient.
And here's where the analysis
gets really stark.
They state flatly there is no
ethical debate inside a
procurement pipeline.
There are only quotas.
Just quotas, not people, not
ethics.
And the system, crucially,
doesn't need to finish
deportation.
It only needs to perpetuate it.
Keep the machine running.
Perpetuate it how?
Well, they break down the
workflow for every single person
caught in it.
Identification, surveillance,
apprehension, detention,
processing, transportation,
adjudication, appeals, removal,
oversight, every single step.
A job, A budget line.
Exactly.
It's designed in a way for
perpetual motion, OK.
Let's talk about the jobs
themselves.
What kind of work does this
deportation economy, as they
call it, actually create?
Well the argument is that it's
replacing obsolete American jobs
with new ones, often blue collar
type work.
Things like tactical driving,
surveillance, biometric
scanning, fence building,
document analysis, private
security stuff.
Where as they put it, no college
required, just a badge, just a
contract.
So echoing the WPA again,
providing work, paid work,
especially for people without
degrees, a strong back, they
said earlier.
Right, but this leads to what
the source is called the obscene
inversion.
Obscene inversion.
Yeah, they even have a kind of
ironic term for it, WPA 2.0, and
they define that as the
reframing of mass deportation
logistics as a domestic economic
revitalization effort, echoing
the New Deal but with inverse
moral implications.
Inverse moral implications
because the original WPA built
things up.
Exactly built cultural, civic
and physical infrastructure
parks, schools, art.
But now this WTA 2 point O uses
public money to dismantle human
presence.
We.
Dismantle human presence.
That's heavy.
It is, they say.
The shovels still dig, the
paycheck still clear.
But the mission is different
This time.
The building is in reverse and
they include this really pointed
quote.
It's easier to get a grant to
build a deportation camp than a
school gymnasium.
Wow, so this isn't just a
temporary thing then?
Not just a policy fad.
Not according to these sources.
They describe it as the new
normal, the post war economy,
post Afghanistan, post
interventionism.
The machine is built to last.
It's the system itself.
That's their bottom line.
This is not a glitch in the
system.
This is the system.
It creates its own support
through budget lines and federal
disbursements.
Money talks basically, as they
put it, kind of cynically.
Perhaps Once the money flows,
ethics become a press release
problem.
The incentives just take over.
Seems to be the argument.
So boiling it all down, what
does this mean for, you know,
for you listening?
You wanted jobs, you wanted
infrastructure spending a strong
economy.
Well, according to this
analysis, this deportation
industrial complex is actually
delivering that, just in a way
nobody really expected.
And the sources leave us with
this final, pretty provocative
thought to chew on.
The deportation state is the new
frontier, and like every
frontier before it, it comes
with maps, missions, boots,
barbed wire and blueprints.
Just like the old frontiers.
The only difference, they say,
is this one doesn't cross
oceans, it crosses
neighborhoods.
And the really unsettling part?
It's already here.
Something to think about how
this new internal frontier might
be changing our communities, our
economy in ways where maybe just
starting to see.